[Música]
en primera plana
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional de france
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
nuestra alimentación y la política que
la rodea hablamos de etiquetados de
información alimentaria para el
consumidor pero también de cómo actúan
los lobbies o grupos de interés
agroalimentarios y sus interactuaciones
con el mundo de la política ya verán qué
interesante nos acompañan tres invitados
joan cortinas muñoz sociólogo docente en
se han especializado en políticas de
salud y alimentación bienvenido joan
gracias carlos que además va a publicar
muy pronto un libro respecto al tema del
que hoy hablamos pilar gala
nutricionista directora de investigación
en epidemiología nutricional bienvenida
y en dúplex a distancia el jean pierre 2
ahora un economista y profesor de la
universidad parís éste y la universidad
austral de chile bienvenido jean-pierre
buenos días gracias por limitación
los beneficios empresariales y la
seguridad alimentaria chocan en la
política legislativa es nuestro tema hoy
en primera plana
sabemos que comer es mucho más que un
placer y una necesidad la dieta y los
hábitos alimenticios son ahora mismo el
factor de salud pública que más puede
ayudarnos a prevenir numerosas
enfermedades desde cáncer hasta diabetes
pero también sabemos que la comida se
traduce en ventas y que existe un
potente lobby agroalimentario que
intenta influir en las políticas de
control y en las autorizaciones un
ejemplo son los millones de euros
invertidos por la industria
agroalimentaria en campañas para evitar
la implantación de etiquetas que
adviertan al consumidor sobre cuestiones
de los ingredientes de los alimentos hoy
nos preguntamos qué poder tienen en
decisiones que afectan a nuestra salud y
ponemos el foco en ese lobby
agroalimentario repasemos antes algunas
portadas revista books el lobby del
azúcar 50 años de intoxicaciones
alimentarias y médicas
revista por la ciencia los desafíos de
la alimentación del campo al plato cómo
se produce es la traza y qué factores la
pueden modificar por el camino y un
ejemplo de lo que hoy hablamos este es
este artículo del diario le monde o
loving contra el nutria score que es el
etiquetado que llevan los productos en
función de si son saludables y que miden
a quién las calorías azúcares o grasas
la salud pública confrontada políticos y
económicos dice el diario
lo dice
haciéndose eco de una tribuna que ha
firmado un grupo de médicos que el año
pasado firmó contra la contraofensiva de
empresas de productos cárnicos y de
quesos que hicieron contra esa
herramienta de la que pilar luego nos va
a explicar su importancia buena nuestra
alimentación es nuestra salud está claro
por tanto el beneficio empresarial a
nivel industrial que es de lo que hoy
hablamos es algo que va a chocar y que
plantea problemas johann en qué momento
estamos respecto a este tema de dónde
venimos estamos mejor estamos peor cuál
es la fotografía del momento la
fotografía del momento respecto al
loving y estamos un poquito mejor es
decir era un tema del que no se hablaba
hace 15 años era un tema absolutamente
silenciado y no obstante los lobbies
están están ahí desde hace mucho tiempo
entonces es un tema que es emergente que
en el debate público está cada vez más
presente y un tema en el cual la gente
cada vez sabe un poquito más gracias a
investigadores o a promotores a lo
público como pilar que van a promover
medidas al público que no existían
respecto que ha sido un sector que ha
estado siempre mucho a la sombra de las
regulaciones y que ahora porque hay
gente que propone cosas el loving es más
visible entonces estamos un poquito
mejor porque se ve más empiece a estar
un poquito regulado pero estamos aún muy
lejos de tener una política de
regulación de la alimentación que sea
satisfactoria en términos de salud
pública pilar vamos a explicar a
nuestros oyentes y telespectadores que
es la epidemiología nutricional es a lo
que éste se dedica la epidemiología
nutricional y un equipo que se ocupa de
la epidemiología nutricional cordón a
grandes estudios que portan sobre un
número muy importante de personas
decenas de miles de personas en las
cuales se estudia las relaciones que
existe entre la nutrición y la salud
evidentemente controlando el resto de
factores socioeconómicos y múltiples
otros factores que pueden intervenir
sobre la patología para ver la parte que
podemos atribuir a la nutrición muy
interesante vamos a profundizar en una
sobre el tema pero antes vamos con
jean-pierre du soleil profesor y
economista en la universidad de parís
este y la universidad austral de chile
que conoce bien el mundo de los lobbies
agroalimentarios y sus estrategias
profesor lo primero cómo funcionan los
lobbies de este sector y qué importancia
tienen en la industria alimentaria es un
problema medicina que existen o bien el
sector agroindustrial cuando existe un
grupo de influencia o presión ongs
sindicatos citibank creado justamente
para defender intereses público y
cuidado partes positivos justamente es
seducir a políticos a que apruebe la
regulación más favorables al interés de
lo partidario la estrategia de los y
fusione ligeramente diferente
dependiendo el país por supuesto un
artículo publicado en el journal of
strategic and management indica que el
lobby por ejemplo francia no es tan bien
visto como el lobby que ser dicen ok
dicho esto podemos suponer que muchas
veces en latinoamérica tampoco es bien
visto la representación de los intereses
privados a través del lobby esto ha sido
estudiado por el observatorio de
multinacionales en américa latina como o
mal
teniendo en cuenta que la agricultura es
generalmente el segundo sector en
importancia del pib en los países la
región con un porcentaje entre 5 y 18
por ciento depende del país según
informaciones del banco mundial por lo
tanto es muy relevante continuar
diciendo políticas que regulen
justamente este login en la alimentación
del sector agroindustrial y
latinoamérica
y joan por cierto va a publicar un libro
el próximo mes de marzo sobre este tema
sobre los lobbies cuando hablamos de la
influencia de los lobbies en la
alimentación pensamos en el caso
emblemático del tocino en eeuu y como
los productores lograron popularizar un
desecho se sigue obedeciendo a este tipo
de métodos como cómo funcionan los
métodos de los lobbies si carlos los
lobbies funciones de manera creo que es
importante que distingamos en el sentido
común la gente la opinión pública ya
genera una idea del lobby como algo que
es un poco escondido o corrupto no que
se acerca un poco de la corrupción de la
de la delincuencia no es para nada eso
el lobby es una profesión el lobby es un
sector muy estructurado muy organizado y
funciona como un sector con profesional
es decir tiene estrategia a largo plazo
tiene organizaciones dedicadas para
influenciar a los científicos a los
políticos a las asociaciones a la
opinión pública entonces hay que verlo
como como un espacio social digamos muy
complejo hecho de muchas múltiples
organizaciones individuos muy
profesionalizados y con muchos recursos
hay que decir que también podemos
utilizar como sinónimo de lobby o grupo
de presión o cabildeo
estamos para no utilizar siempre el
anglicismo un ejemplo clásico de
herramienta que no gusta a los lobbies
son los etiquetados que permiten
transparencia respecto a cuán saludables
son los productos que comemos por
ejemplo el nutrias corzos semáforo pilar
cómo funciona esta herramienta quien
hace las evaluaciones de los productos
si el primero explicar un poco que es el
nutrias corel se nutrió score es un
logotipo nutricional que está que se
posiciona en la cara anterior de los
envases para sus un poco para qué
el consumidor comprenda cuál es la
calidad nutricional del producto de una
forma simple e intuitiva sin tener que
mirar la tabla de composición de los
alimentos que está la
del alimento y de forma que tiene dos
objetivos el primero es
informar al consumidor sobre la calidad
nutricional de los alimentos para que
pueda si lo desea modificar la selección
según la calidad y nutricional del
alimento y el otro objetivo es animar a
los industriales a mejorar la
composición nutricional de los alimentos
de forma que como es un logotipo color y
al que el alimento en cuestión mejor
dado desde el punto de vista en la
calidad nutricional tendrá una
clasificación mejor en el nutrition y de
forma gráfica
un logotipo basado en cinco colores que
van del verde al rojo
superpuesto de cinco letras que van de
la letra a a la letra y evidentemente
detrás hay un cálculo que tiene en
cuenta los componentes nutricionales que
se consideran positivos para la salud y
los que se han demostrado
científicamente que son negativos para
la salud y esto da lugar a un logotipo
que informa a la población en el momento
llegas en un supermercado y hay centenas
de cereales decenas de yogures platos
cocinados a escoger el que tiene mejor
calidad nutricional fue de polk
desarrollado por nuestro equipo
realmente nuestro equipo no
tiene ningún financiamiento de la
industria agroalimentaria y
en cualquier caso es un ejemplo de una
herramienta podríamos tomar otras por
ejemplo en méxico esos avisos de comida
chatarra que se impusieron de hace poco
y como fue impresión de como los lobbies
reaccionan cada vez que una de estas
herramientas se ponen en funcionamiento
es las reacciones son impresionantes no
sé si que existen estas reacciones tan
potentes de los lobbies significa que la
política está actuando claro y ya
evidentemente los vemos los vemos cuando
hay una propuesta de salud pública y
evidentemente ahí se ve la potencia del
lobby pero lo que me parece interesante
de señalar es que los lobbies no sólo
actúan cuando los vemos algo como decían
los lobbies siempre están allí y hacen
estrategias de 10 15 20 años entonces no
es porque no tenemos que pensar que eso
actúan de manera puntual actual
sistemáticamente y sólo para para daros
un ejemplo no y lo vemos a la decisión
pública pero los lobbies actúan mucho en
ciencias louis de ellas antes como
actúan en ciencia igual quieres abordar
lo que podemos abordar porque igual que
hay
evidencias científicas los lobbies me
imagino también producen literatura
científica
entrecomillamos la literatura científica
cómo trabajan esos grupos de presión
para producir literatura para producir
estudio eso es muy importante lo que
estás diciendo hay que pensar el lobby
como un camaleón el trabajo del lobby es
adaptarse al contexto en el que va a
trabajar con el que quiere trabajar
entonces ellos trabajan en el campo de
la decisión pública pero mucho en el
campo científico en el campo asociativo
y filantrópico esos los tres campos de
influencia en la ciencia cómo lo van a
hacer pues ellos no van a hacer
pseudociencia no es verdad muchas veces
producen ciencia de verdad lo que hacen
es orientar el tipo de preguntas que nos
vamos a hacer pero son trabajos que son
absolutamente metodológicamente bastante
buenos en general es decir por ejemplo
en francia es la industria lechera
financia muchos estudios sobre es que
los productos lácteos pueden tener un
efecto positivo sobre para prevenir las
enfermedades degenerativas neuronales
vale eso puede existir lo que pasa que
financiando este tipo de estudios se
olvidan las consecuencias negativas que
los productos lecheros pueden pueden
tener porque no se hace investigación
sobre los productos lecheros tienen una
influencia sobre el cáncer de próstata
como no se financia este tipo de
estudios solo sabemos una parte de la
verdad pero es verdad una ciencia que
trabaja
para un lado y del que se puede firmar
pero en ciencia porque está hecho por
investigó no siempre por muchos casos
puedes dar hecha por investigadores de
la universidad defender a hablar muchas
veces
saben a qué equipo digo muchas veces no
es sistemáticos a qué equipo dirigirse y
tienen una estrategia que es muy bien
rodada se crean relaciones casi de
amistad con los investigadores se pagan
congresos se pagan mesas redondas
específicas donde quieren que traten su
tema específico
la invitan a conferenciantes que saben
que van a aportar
informaciones que no son totalmente
amplias como tú lo has dicho entonces lo
que hay que pensar es que los lobbies
siempre que hay una medida de salud
pública que toca a sus intereses
económicos los lobbies están ahí para
bloquear esa medida de salud pública voy
a hacer en este punto una breve pausa y
enseguida seguimos hablando de cómo
actúan los lobbies zero como grupos de
interés agroalimentarios a quien en
primera plana hasta ahora
en la cee del cono sur a norte américa
de los andes' a centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
france 24
enlace en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
seguimos aquí en primera plana esta
semana hablando de los grupos de interés
o los lobbies agroalimentarios y la
importancia como choca eso con las
políticas de salud públicas lo hacemos
con jon cortinas muñoz sociólogo docente
en xian especializado en políticas de
salud pilar galán nutricionista
directora de investigación en
epidemiología nutricional y jean-pierre
de solán economista y profesor de la
universidad parís este en este asunto
joan es algo los lobbies que ha existido
toda la vida en alquízar somos más
conscientes porque la conciencia del
consumidor también ha aumentado y porque
somos más conscientes del tema que
abordamos hoy en el programa seguramente
este es un elemento importante el
segundo elemento importante es lo que
decía al principio las enfermedades
crónicas o pérez ya pilar están muy
vinculadas con heladas viendo sólo la
única causa está muy corre las con el
tipo de alimentación que tenemos eso
cada vez lo sabemos más y esa conciencia
o es evidencia científica hace que los
poderes públicos no puedan ser ciegos de
esta realidad entonces eso hace que se
tenga que actuar en salud pública y ahí
los lobbies que hasta el momento en
alimentación había muy poca regulación
ahora se empieza a querer regular porque
es importante saberlo ellos siempre
están a favor de la regulación de la
demanda la demanda quiere decir hacer
educación que la gente esté al tanto de
ciertas cosas pero no quieren que servir
la oferta la oferta es qué tipo de
productos podemos vender qué tipo de
publicidad se puede hacer de los propios
alimenticios eso es lo que ellos quieren
bloquear sistemáticamente no entonces
hay una toma de conciencia porque hay
una que realidad de salud pública es que
la enfermedades crónicas es la primera
causa de mortalidad si no me equivoco en
los países occidentales le voy a
preguntar a ella amplia gattuso land
porque hay campos donde estos lobbies
visto desde afuera actúan especialmente
por ejemplo el azúcar o el alcohol
cuando el poder legislativo intenta
luchar contra los altos contenidos de
azúcar de los alimentos qué estrategias
utilizan para hacer el contrapunto a la
evidencia científica que prueba que el
azúcar es malo para la salud las
empresas a veces se oponen a una nueva
regulación o bien a un restricción en la
regulación munición producto de la
industria su carrera de los años 60 como
sabemos y financió por favorecer el
estudio llegó incluían que las grasas
saturadas era la principal responsable
de las enfermedades cardíacas y no el
propio azúcar esto se mencionó
justamente como parte de un lobby
tomando en cuenta que generalmente estos
alimentos procesados y ricos su pérez
son económicos y son consumidos
generalmente por los sectores
socioeconómicos más desfavorecidos esto
también puede ser explicado lateral con
un libro mío un poco lo que yo me dijo
pues la creación de mantención de la
industria de asimetrías de información
ya que los consumidores que representan
las industrias justamente que resulta la
demanda y muchas veces no solamente no
tienen el dinero para comprar los
productos más naturales sino que además
el envase del producto no permite
conocer fácilmente la composición
nutricional del alimento y se hace
necesario un sistema adicional de
etiquetado frontal que produzca esta
simple información juntamente y permita
mejorar elección y tener una elección
mucho más formal los lobbies que también
actúan contra herramientas como las que
nos narraba antes pilar como el nutri
score de herramientas que faciliten la
toma de decisión al consumidor y que
aporten transparencia a pilar cómo
actúan estos lobbies contras con contras
herramientas como el nutrias core están
muy bien estructurados o tiene tienen
etapas muy bien definidas que intentan
la primera es intentan bloque en la
medida de salud pública que les molesta
desde el punto de vista económico y van
a enviar en francia por ejemplo correos
a los ministros que les son los más
próximos como el ministro de la
agricultura a diputados y van a utilizar
elementos del lenguaje para desee
desacreditar esta medida de salud
pública
estigmatizante
reductora
infantilizante y además van a aportar
argumentos que son los suyos sobre las
consecuencias que esta medidas de salud
pública van a tener en términos
económicos escogen las pequeñas empresas
o en la pérdida de empleo y lo que es
muy interesante es que estos aspectos de
lenguaje vamos a encontrarlos después en
los hombres políticos que vemos la
influencia que ha tenido los acción de
los lobbies
en los hombres políticos en los
discursos de el ministro de la
agricultura y después cuando no pueden
bloquearlo lo que van a intentar es
retardar la medida retardar su
aplicación pero lo hacen de forma
realmente escandalosa o sea a nivel de
diputados tú sabes que cuando se va a
votar una ley hay enmiendas entonces
ellos lo que hacen los revistas es
rellenar el papel del diputado con sus
argumentos y sus elementos del lenguaje
para que sean defendidos de forma a
bloquear en el voto el hecho de que esta
medida se ha tomado muy interesante lo
que nos cuente apilar cómo interactúan
los lobbies con con la clase política lo
cual nos lleva a plantearnos otra
cuestión ahora mismo asistimos una
campaña electoral en francia joan
podemos hablar de otros países también
porque este tema se plantea tampoco en
campaña y sobre todo sólo a partir de
polémicas porque este tema no toma más
relevancia en el espacio público hablar
de este tema y tan importantes para
nuestra salud muy buena pregunta
la alimentación como podemos imaginar
tiene 22 dimensiones de la dimensión
material la económica o material los
alimentos la dimensión simbólica en el
caso alimentación la dimensión simbólica
es muy importante
en todos los países la alimentación está
vinculada a la identidad nacional en
todos en españa italia francia 2 vayas
donde vayas cuando viene un turista que
quiere enseñar ir a comer en un
restaurante etcétera es ese elemento es
muy importante y eso explica que hay una
especie de consenso social sobre la
importancia de alimentación para nuestra
cultura etcétera eso genera que en
términos del mercado político no es muy
rentable atacarse a la alimentación
porque porque no hay muchos descensos en
el campo de alimentación es decir no hay
miles de asociaciones que trabajan para
la salud pública y de oficio y hay un
consenso social cultural y esa es la
batalla del lobby el globe y no quiere
que eso cambie es su batalla es muy
simbólica y es de hegemonía cultural la
en francia el queso no se puede tocar en
italia el jamón de parma es intocable
ese es el corazón digamos de la batalla
del dominó pilar
añadiría el hecho de que actualmente
estamos viviendo situaciones muy
inquietantes desde el punto de vista
económico y
electoralista porque grupos de partidos
populistas nacionalistas
por ejemplo en italia como matteo
salvini entonces van a utilizar un tipo
de terminología que utiliza
el patriotismo culinario e incluso
cuando van a hablar de la dieta
mediterránea van a deformar la porque
para decir que los quesos y la
charcutería que se pueden comer con
placer siempre que se coma de forma no
excesiva moderada son pilares de la
dieta mediterránea ningún experto en
nutrición y en salud pública va a
considerar que es cierto porque es una
mentira y entonces ellos van a
considerar que estamos atacados joan tú
lo has dicho a la al jamón al
al queso y en francia se vive
actualmente esta situación porque
estamos en periodo electoral de forma
que se promueven alimentos que no son
saludables
porque las personas que nos promueven el
queso el jamón o la charco y otros tipos
de charcutería son electos en las
regiones que producen estos productos o
son candidatos entonces estamos viviendo
una situación
que es muy inquietante en términos de
salud muy interesante hablamos de los
lobbies de cómo actuar en francia
también vamos a mirar a américa latina
para comparar un poco con europa porque
lógicamente son realidades que a veces
no tienen mucho que ver ya ampliar
tienen estos lobbies allí el terreno en
américa latina' las cosas más fáciles
recordemos las resistencias por ejemplo
que creo el etiquetado de comida
chatarra en méxico al que me refería yo
antes en transferencia su consulta es
necesario no es una europa al igual que
eeuu cuenta con una estructura mucho más
desarrollado del lobby en latinoamérica
estudios indican que bruselas existen
entre 15 y 20 y 30 mil revistas que
trabajan en temas políticos temas
económicos agrícolas medioambientales
como por ejemplo el lobby del tabaco de
las farmacéuticas y de las productoras
de semillas transgénicas y agroquímicos
por mencionar algunos temas estos sólo
superado por el lobby que se hace en
tingo éxitos edición eeuu se llama
referencia latinoamérica la tarea de un
lobbista sería más fácil si no existiera
una legislación pero afortunadamente
como sabemos se ha creado un sistema de
etiquetado frontal en uruguay chile en
perú en mexico por nombre algunos países
estos nuevos estándares son un éxito
para ser comercializado estos productos
por ejemplo en escuelas y cumplir con
los estándares nutricionales del sistema
de compras también del estado esto
favorece la producción de alimentos más
naturales a través de la agricultura de
proximidad y el circuito corto
este cambio como sabemos representa un
gran desafío para los consumidores a
través de los cambios de hábitos
alimenticios pero también un tremendo
esfuerzo para las industrias del sector
es muy intención generoso mala obra y
muchas veces de los cuales no cuentan
con mucha inversión como lo es el sector
hay mucha eléctrica
uno de los argumentos estrella de los
lobbies es el de la libertad el de la
libertad de elección quizá la pregunta
también que nos podemos formular si el
estado debe proteger al ciudadano de la
obesidad de la diabetes y del
alcoholismo qué respuesta damos a esto
johann desde las políticas de salud
pública a la salud pública porque es un
posicionamiento político que el estado
debe proteger no sí bueno digamos unas
primeras misiones del estado es proteger
a la población eso no es un policía
mente político eso está escrito la
constitución de lo que es la función del
estado luego la discusión dentro ese
perímetro que es que el estado se debe
de proteger a la población hasta qué
punto evidentemente pero no da nadie
habla de prohibición que ayudaría nunca
escuchaba a alguien de salud pública que
al seguir que proviene o así hablar de
regulación que no vas a vender no se
venden productos que son tóxicos para la
gente no le tabaco ya está muy regulado
porque se sabe que es tóxico bueno pues
estamos hablando lo mismo cómo hacemos
para evitar que haya productos muy
tóxicos consumidos para la población y
que afecten y que intentemos bajar la
prevalencia enfermedades crónicas que
están matando mucha gente cada año se
trata de muertes no estamos hablando de
libertad no hay libertad para morir
seguramente pero estamos como hacemos
podemos hacer que los productos sean
menos tóxicos claro que se puede hacer
reduzcamos el contenido en azúcares en
grasas saturadas sólo se habla de eso es
decir quién quiere consumir productos
tóxicos demás sin saberlo porque hasta
el 23 core nadie sabía lo que contenía
ese producto consiste en dar información
al consumidor para eso pero también
consiste en estructurar la fehr y la
última frase que en este quedará sin
tiempo
los lobbies lo que no quieren es
reglamentar las cosas porque
reglamentando no pueden continuar a auto
o regularse ellos entonces toda medida
de salud pública importante como la
regulación de la publicidad en 20 años
de lucha tanto por diputados incluso por
algunas caras de la salida de tiempo no
se ha conseguido muchísimas gracias es
muy interesante lo en primera plana de
esta semana de todos ustedes hasta la
próxima semana gracias
[Música]